j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
cette émission et c'est une décennie à
la tête de la CFDT que l'on va analyser
Laurent Berger qui ne son poste de
secrétaire général à la fois sur un
échec la réforme des retraites va
s'appliquer et sur un succès sont
syndicat est devenu le premier en France
pendant son mandat avant de débattre sur
son avenir sur celui de l'intersyndicale
aussi le portrait de Laurent Berger
signé Samia de chien allez allez c'est
une tradition à la CFDT tous les 10 ans
le syndicat change de dirigeant en 2012
François cherec laisse donc sa place à
Laurent Berger inconnue du grand public
il devient à 44 ans secrétaire général
d'un syndicat réformiste une position
d'équilibriste sous un gouvernement de
gauche les soutien d'un gouvernement ni
opposant politique mais contre-pouvoir
social autonome et exigeant la CFDT est
fidèle à elle-même gué Laurent Berger
vient d'une famille militante fils d'un
ouvrier sur les chantiers de
Saint-Nazaire et d'une auxiliaire de
puériculture il forge son engagement
lors de ses années d'études à Nantes au
jeunesse ouvrières chrétiennes dont il
sera un temps responsable mais surtout à
la CFDT
salariés d'une association d'insertion
il devient responsable de l'Union
Régionale Pays de la Loire c'est là
qu'il a connu Yvan Ricordeau dont les
années 90 un ami de plus de 30 ans qu'il
l'a vu gravir tous les échelons jusqu'à
prendre la tête du syndicat réformiste
comme nous il est simple comme nous
quand on est dans un débat il parle de
la même façon il a le même quotidien
d'ailleurs et donc ça permet une forme
de légitimité et puis en même temps des
atouts qu'il a dans sa poche depuis le
départ c'est un très gros bosseur
c'est quelqu'un qui qui respecte
beaucoup ses interlocuteurs sous
François Hollande Laurent Berger va
défendre plusieurs réformes impopulaires
à gauche comme la loi travail adoptée
par 49,3 malgré tout en 2018 la CFDT
devient le premier syndicat de France
devant la CGT une victoire pour Laurent
Berger réélu la même année à plus de 90%
des voix sous Emmanuel Macron le
dialogue social se durcit en 2019 il
emmène son syndicat dans la rue contre
un premier projet de réforme des
retraites finalement abandonnés 4 ans
plus tard nouvelle réforme des retraites
nouvelle mobilisation 64 ans c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible on en veut
pas et donc il faut que le gouvernement
écoute s'il écoute pas on recommencera
pour la première fois depuis 2010 la
CFDT et la CGT des films mains dans la
main Laurent Berger aux côtés de
Philippe Martinez en tête de cortège les
deux hommes se connaissent bien ils se
sont côtoyés pendant 8 ans à la tête des
deux premiers syndicats de France ils
auraient pu ne pas s'entendre et
pourtant il s'apprécie
Philippe Martinez respectant lui l'homme
de terrain forcément on n'a pas toujours
été d'accord sur le fond mais je crois
que on a réussi à dépasser ce qui nous
divisait pour essayer de travailler ce
qui pouvait nous rassembler et il est
proche des militants je vous l'ai dit se
déplace beaucoup il va beaucoup au
contact et c'est quelqu'un qui est
sincère je l'ai dit qu'elle a la même
conception du rôle de dirigeant
c'est quelqu'un qui quand il dit quelque
chose il change pas d'avis donc
forcément ça ça ne pouvait que coller
sur ces bases là redevenu simple
militant Philippe Martinez à passer la
main à Sophie Binet il y a trois mois
demain Laurent Berger qui traduit aussi
la tête de la CFDT au profit de Marylise
Léon après 11 ans sous le feu des
projecteurs il reste lui aussi fidèle à
la tradition de son syndicat au bout
d'une décennie il faut savoir c'est de
sa place
pas besoin et on tourne cette page avec
Christine kerdeland bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes ici journaliste économique
auteur de ce livre mon super héros aux
éditions humaines sciences Frank Morel
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi à vos
cassocier chez Clichy Grangé ancien
conseiller social d'Edouard Philippe
expert emploi l'Institut Montaigne Rémi
bourguignon bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes directeur scientifique de la
chair transformation et régulation de la
relation de travail c'est à l'Université
Paris Est Créteil et Laetitia cruppa
évidemment est resté à mes côtés petit
exercice de style Laurent Berger en
alors ça peut être un mot un souvenir
une date clé Christine kerelland vous
diriez quoi qu'est-ce qui vient
un mot c'est honnetum
honnête homme d'ailleurs au sens du 19e
siècle d'une certaine façon aussi c'est
un peu ce que disait Martinez tout de
suite il est il se tient aux décisions
qu'il prend il est honnête là après
apparemment après son mandat enfin à
partir de la fin de la semaine prochaine
il va sortir avec un sac à dos une tente
pour marcher tout seul pendant une
semaine en Bretagne et puis ceux qui
mettent sur un petit garçon non une
semaine mais tout le monde c'est déjà
bien
au Parlement pour faire accepter la
majorité UMP de l'époque des
dispositions sur le dialogue social dans
les TPE et il avait fini par intégrer
cette contrainte mais ça va pas été ça
avait pas été si évident non je dirais
que c'est quelqu'un dans durant les 10
ans qu'il a été à la tête de la CFDT qui
a voulu rester dans l'ADN ce que vous
disiez il y a quelques secondes de la
CFDT mais j'ai envie de dire que quand
on aura laissé passer un peu l'écume je
dirais du regard immédiat sur
l'actualité on se dira que dans cette
période à la différence de la période de
son prédécesseur il n'y a pas eu de
grandes avancées de la part de la CFDT
dans les négociations
interprofessionnelles il y avait eu
juste au début de son mandat l'accord de
2013 voilà mais au tout début
effectivement qui a été négocié avant
lui l'accord de 2013 sur la sécurisation
de l'emploi qui a modifié les règles de
licenciement économique et qui a
généralisé la complémentaire santé qui
était pour les salariés qui étaient une
de la CFDT il y avait eu je l'ai vécu au
ministère du Travail en 2008 la refonte
des règles de représentativité des
organisations syndicales dans laquelle
la CFDT avait joué un rôle majeur et
donc si le critère effectivement c'est
ce critère là on peut porter un regard
un peu plus nuancé alors certes la CFDT
est devenu le premier syndicat pendant
les 10 ans ou Laurent Berger était à sa
tête mais surtout du fait de
l'affaiblissement de la CGT c'est
surtout alors on y reviendra
effectivement là dessus je vous
interrompre pour donner la parole à Rémi
bourguignon peut-être qu'il y a il y a
une bascule pour vous dans dans ce dans
cette décennie de Laurent Berger à la à
la tête de la CFDT c'est quoi oui oui il
y a clairement une bascule alors qui est
pas tellement dans la dans la politique
menée par Laurent Berger parce que
j'aurais aussi insisté sur la la
constance à la fois dans la continuité
de ces prédécesseurs mais sa constance à
lui dans dans sa conception de l'action
syndicale et et du réformisme tel qu'il
le définit mais en tout cas il y a eu un
effectivement une bascule dans ses 10
ans c'est dans la manière dont les
gouvernement ont traité la démocratie
sociale alors effectivement Franck Morel
rappelait à l'instant il y a eu un début
de parcours de Laurent Berger qui était
dans un contexte plutôt favorable avec
François Hollande qui avait décidé de
réformer par le dialogue social et cette
réforme la loi sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi est assez emblématique d'une
des grandes réussites de la démocratie
sociale avec des mesures assez courageux
pour des organisations syndicales qui
ont été prises à ce moment-là suivis par
le pouvoir politique et donc dans ce
mandat de François Hollande et voilà et
un point de basculer à un moment ça se
dégrade
2015 où on voit bien qu'il y a un
changement de méthode assez radical qui
va s'incarner dès les lois el khomri et
qui va être poursuivi derrière sous
Emmanuel Macron et qui est de réformer
cette fois non plus avec la démocratie
sociale mais avec un pouvoir politique
fort et assume et puis Christine cardan
il y a une autre date importante qui est
le conflit des gilets jaunes
parce que alors là on est évidemment
avec Emmanuel Macron mais pourquoi elle
est importante dans dans parliez
démocratie démocratie sociale démocratie
politique dans le la perception par
Laurent Berger finalement de son rôle du
rôle des syndicats et peut-être d'une
occasion manquée il y a deux choses à la
fois c'était un mouvement social qui ne
dépendait pas du tout des syndicats qui
n'a pas été impulsé par les syndicats
donc c'était une claque terrible pour
eux d'être récupérée par les syndicats
refusé d'être récupérés et vraiment à
distance tout à fait même tout principe
d'être représenté par qui que ce soit
effectivement
et en même temps il a attendu la main à
ce moment-là à Emmanuel Macron en disant
voilà ce mouvement nous dépasser si on
te faire quelque chose ensemble et la
main n'a pas été saisie donc il y a je
pense qu'il y a une double pas défaite
mais une double déception en tout cas
pour lui mais je voudrais juste
compléter j'étais pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous sur sur ce qui s'est
passé pendant le pendant son son mandat
moi je pense que si aujourd'hui le
chômage est assez peu provocateur ce que
veut dire et si aujourd'hui le chômage
est le plus bas depuis 40 ans s'il est à
7%, c'est en partie grâce à lui parce
que les les réformes sociales qui ont
commencé à la fin du mandat Hollande la
loi travail ou etc il est à l'époque il
était encore en négociation avec avec
François Hollande et c'est et c'est
grâce à la comment dire la CFDT ou en
tout cas au fait que la CFDT n'est pas
descendue dans la rue et a laissé les
choses se faire que la politique de
l'offre a pu commencer qu'elle a
continué soi-même Macron ou là
effectivement la CFDT était pas du tout
d'accord avec la réforme du Code du
travail et avec d'autres mesures qui ont
été prises mais sont toutes ces mesures
là qui quand même on fait ont eu pour
résultat aujourd'hui cette cette baisse
du chômage le fait que les entreprises
n'ont plus peur d'embaucher
la question non la question vient de de
quand est-ce qu'on date le la genèse de
ces réformes-là moi je considère que la
ce qui a déclenché effectivement le
mouvement en direction de ces réformes
là c'est la réforme de 2008 parce que
c'est la réforme de 2008 qui a fait le
choix résolu de mettre l'entreprise avec
la position commune signée par la CGT la
CFDT et donc le prédécesseur de Laurent
Berger effectivement
et donc c'est cette position commune et
la réforme de 2008 qui a fait le choix
de mettre l'entreprise au cœur du
système les réformes qui ont suivi ont
amplifié le processus qui avait été
ouvert par la réforme de 2008 mais bon
après c'est un débat
et je voudrais qu'on entende une
première fois Laurent Berger dans ce
dans ce débat il revient évidemment sur
ces six mois de combat contre la réforme
des retraites qui ont forcément changé
son image écoutez ce qu'il en dit
c'était dimanche sur France Inter
pourquoi un syndicaliste comme moi
mesuré quelle sens du compromis qui
pense qu'il y a pas de grand soir et qui
a pas de Yaka faucon à tous les étages
que pourquoi on considère que pourquoi
je me fais le relais aujourd'hui de
cette colère là parce qu'elle existe et
qu'elle existe parmi ceux et celles qui
ont été là qui ont été là notamment
pendant cette période enfin on n'a pas
tiré les périodes
le bilan de la période de la crise
sanitaire ça a bouleversé la société
Rémi bourguignon alors c'est ma question
elle est volontairement binaire un peu
simpliste mais est-ce que Laurent Berger
c'est radicalisé pendant ce combat
contre la réforme des retraites non je
crois pas
il a d'ailleurs plusieurs fois pendant
cette mobilisation redit qu'il était
tout à fait prêt à accompagner une
réforme il était même plutôt porteur et
il soutenait la réforme version 2019 qui
était pour le coup une réforme
ambitieuse on peut se demander si les
retraites c'est vraiment une réforme on
n'a pas réformé le système de retraite
on a fait quelques ajustements qui sont
plutôt des de mon budgétaire il n'y a
pas eu de réformes donc il était lui
plutôt porteur d'une idée plus
réformatrice que le gouvernement donc il
est pas revenu sur sa conception du
curéformisme par contre cette opposition
sur la mesure d'âge et bien il l'avait
affirmé très tôt il s'y est tenu et
d'ailleurs il est un peu dans le
prolongement de de ces prédécesseurs
puisque ça a été rappelé dans votre
reportage d'introduction mais en 2010
déjà il y avait une opposition très
forte de la CFDT à la réforme des
retraites qui était aussi une réforme
qui visait à bouger l'âge de la retraite
et de ce point de vue là la CFDT n'a pas
changé de ligne de conduite bon donc
vous nous dites qu'il y a une cohérence
je propose à Audrey beta de nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau puisque on va
faire un peu le bilan le bilan notamment
en nombre d'adhérents etc etc lorsqu'il
annonce son départ rebonsoir Audrey
c'était dans une interview journal de
monde dit je vais partir
à la mi-juin il affirme je laisserai une
CFDT qui va bien est-ce qu'il a raison
déjà un point qu'on ne peut pas lui
contester vous l'avez rappelé c'est sous
son air que la sfdt est devenue en 2018
le premier de France devant la CGT elle
compte aujourd'hui 640
000 adhérents sous la houlette de
Laurent Berger la ligne réformiste c'est
progressivement imposée parmi les autres
positions syndicales écoutez le sénateur
sans triste Hervé Marseille à ce sujet
il incarne quelque part ce qui manque
aujourd'hui cette gauche sociale
démocrate ce courant modérée qui apporte
beaucoup traditionnellement à la vie du
pays
mais alors paradoxalement on pourrait
dire que c'est grâce à l'opposition
résolue de Laurent Berger à la réforme
des retraites que la CFDT a gagné des
adhérents et oui aussi la CFDT à renoué
avec les manifestations un mode de
contestation qu'elle avait délaissé ces
dernières années ça a permis d'augmenter
son audience c'est incontestable d'après
Laurent Berger lui-même elle compte
50000 adhérents de plus depuis le début
d'année et des centaines de sections ont
été créés je vous propose de l'écouter
aussi à ce sujet Laurent Berger
le syndicalisme est de retour il est de
retour pas simplement dans la rue il est
retour dans les entreprises les retours
dans les chiffres de d'adhérents on
entend beaucoup les partis politiques et
notamment le parti présidentiel expliqué
qu'ils font des campagnes d'adhésion je
crois que le nombre de nouveaux
adhérents à la CFDT depuis début janvier
c'est à peu près plus que le nombre
global d'adhérents de nombre de partis
politiques alors satisfaite au Laurent
Berger à nuancé évidemment la CFDT comme
les autres syndicats n'échappent pas à
l'hémorragie générale des adhésions les
nouveaux venus ne compensent pas
forcément les départs la CFDT aurait
perdu en 10 ans 200 000 adhérents il
faut souligner aussi que la France reste
l'un des pays les moins syndiqués de
l'Union européenne avec un taux de 10,3%
d'après la DARES quand la moyenne
européenne est de 24% homme merci
beaucoup Audrey Rémy bourguignon je
reste avec vous sur cette phrase de
Laurent Berger le syndicalisme est de
retour si vous êtes d'accord avec ça
alors on verra si le syndicalisme est de
retour en tout cas sur la réforme des
retraites ça n'a pas bien fonctionné
cette opposition syndicale puisque la
réforme est quand même allée au bout
donc on a entendu les syndicats nous
dire qu'ils avaient des vagues
d'adhésion on n'a pas vraiment de
chiffres donc c'est des c'est leur
déclarations et on entendait peut-être
que ça va améliorer leur audience on
verra bien l'audience qu'on la connaîtra
dans quelques temps pour le moment on ne
sait pas que ça va changer pour ces
syndicats mais il y a peut-être un
retour et une un regard des cinq cas
mais pour le moment ils n'ont pas réussi
à convaincre encore le pouvoir politique
ils ont un rôle à jouer dans la réforme
c'est à dire on n'a pas le sentiment que
le gouvernement a changé d'avis
fondamentalement et se dit que désormais
pour réformer il va s'appuyer il y a eu
quelques petits gestes mais c'est
vraiment à la marge donc c'est un peu ça
le c'est pas le bilan de Laurent Berger
mais on disait tout à l'heure il a
démarré son son mandat de secrétaire
général dans un contexte plutôt
favorable avec des liens forts avec le
pouvoir politique et le terminent dans
un contexte où le pouvoir politique et
les démocratie sociale sont très
opposées et donc c'est il part avec un
contexte global qui est beaucoup plus
défavorable au syndical que pardon est
opposé à la démocratie sociale qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire
dans la bouche Laurent Berger pendant
les six derniers mois et là on l'a eu en
temps dans la vôtre qu'est-ce que ça
signifie c'est l'idée que le pour
réformer le le gouvernement ne souhaite
pas en passer par un travail des
partenaires sociaux organisation
patronale organisation syndicale qui
puisse avec leur expertise eux-mêmes
concevoir préparer les réformes comme
cela est d'ailleurs pourtant prévu dans
le cadre légal puisque il faut se
rappeler qu'après la grand conflit de
2006 sur le CPE la loi Larcher avait
prévu que désormais quand on souhaitait
réformer
question de travail et d'emplois et bien
il fallait en passer par une phase
préalable qui était de confier le
dossier aux organisations syndicales et
patronales pour qu'elles négocie si elle
s'entendent le gouvernement s'engage à
suivre la réforme si en revanche bien
sûr en gardant son pouvoir et sa
capacité à revenir bien sûr partie du
débat non mais bien sûr mais en
repartant quand même de l'accord qui
peut être signé entre l'organisation
syndicale et patronale et se bien sûr
son pouvoir de législateur et le
Parlement peut bien sûr intervenir mais
quand même repartir de ce travail de pré
législateur fait par les organisations
syndicales et patronales et donc ça vous
nous dites que ça c'est pas appliqué
très très peu de loi depuis 2013 en tout
cas on n'a pas vu de réformes sur cette
oui mais on peut pas dire que ce n'est
pas appliqué le processus est appliqué
le processus n'implique pas forcément
qu'il y ait une négociation et un accord
le processus implique que la perche soit
tendue aux partenaires sociaux qui est
soit une négociation soit une
concertation alors c'est vrai que depuis
2013 il n'y a pas eu de grand accord
national interprofessionnels
prélégiférant mais je trouve que c'est
un peu facile de peindre le monde en
noir et en blanc et de considérer que
c'est uniquement la responsabilité des
pouvoirs publics pour négocier il faut
être plusieurs et quand on met sur la
table une possible négociation on se
pose la question de ce qu'on est prêt à
donner et de ce qu'on est prêt à obtenir
ce qu'il faut pointer c'est que par
exemple dans la cour nationale de 2013
la CFDT a obtenu à l’époque la
généralisation de la complémentaire
santé au prix d'un assouplissement des
règles sur le licenciement économique
collectif qui était prêt à donner par
exemple prenons l'exemple des retraites
qui était prêt à donner la CFDT dans le
cadre de la réforme des retraites j'ai
pas trouvé dans les déclarations même
même les questions de nombre d'amnités
qui un temps avaient pu être dans le
débat la porte a été fermée très très
tôt donc je pense qu'il y a aussi le
débat qui peut y avoir sur la démocratie
sociale est un débat extrêmement
intéressant et pertinent mais la
démocratie sociale c'est pas
le pouvoir public donne un blanc saint
aux partenaires sociaux le laissant
faire ce qu'ils veulent et en recopiant
religieusement c'est quelque chose qui
vient des deux parties qui est conçu par
les deux parties
un exemple récent l'accord sur le
partage de la valeur en entreprise donc
là c'est un accord patrona syndicat et
que le gouvernement s'est engagé à
reprendre oui mais il s'est fait sans le
gouvernement effectivement entre le
Medef et un certain nombre de syndicats
et d'ailleurs c'est une des fiertés de
Laurent Berger et il espère que on va
continuer sur cette voie là c'est à dire
lui ne s'entendait plus avec les gens
qui étaient au gouvernement et il a été
ravi de pouvoir négocier avec Geoffrey
Bézieux et il Medef sur le partage de la
valeur dans les entreprises votre avis
sur le lien de confiance entre parce que
c'est une partie de la chronique de
d'Audrey à l'instant entre les Français
et les syndicats quand Laurent Berger
les syndicalisme de retour c'est un peu
ça qui a derrière on a gagné des
adhérents à l'occasion de cette réforme
des retraites sauf que vous l'avez dit
bah la loi elle est passée donc à moyen
terme est-ce que ce lien de confiance ou
est-ce que ces adhérents vont rester
c'est une vraie question qu'ils doivent
se poser là je trouve qu'il a un
paradoxe à dire que effectivement les
syndicats ont perdu on a eu 14 journées
de défilés de manifestation qui n'ont
servi à rien et en même temps ils ont
fait la démonstration une certaine
manière que la démocratie sociale mais
c'est pas tout se faire le même sens que
le vôtre fonctionnait mieux qu'il y a
démocratie de parlementaire et on a vu
un fouillis un désordre à l'Assemblée
nationale c'était la chanlie vraiment et
en revanche dans la rue on a vu les
syndicats et leurs adhérents faire
preuve de responsabilité de de sagesse
en quelque sorte et au même si ça n'a
aboutit à rien mais je pense et en plus
très bien pendant très bien tenir les
manifestations jusqu'au 49-3 après le
49-3 il y a eu plus de violences mais
c'est vrai que les manifestations au
final ils ont ils ont gagné ils sortent
plutôt gagnants de cette de cette
séquence alors et puis avec évidemment
et on va ouvrir ce chapitre la question
de l'interdy syndicale de l'unité
syndicale qui était inédite et qui est
qui s'est avéré solide ça peut ça a pu
en tout cas sembler surprenant écoutez
ce qu'on dit justement Laurent Berger
enfin on va le lire plutôt parce que
c'est en dans un long portrait que les
échos consacrent à leur aubergé
aujourd'hui portrait passionnant alors
voilà ce qu'il dit à propos de la de
l'Inter syndicale nous nous sommes
respectés on a travaillé en transparence
quand vous êtes capable de dire aux
autres ça je ne pourrais pas vous avez
gagné car nous savons tous ce que c'est
que de gérer des organisations
collectives il y a beaucoup les
informations intéressantes dans cette
première phrase et puis ensuite il dit
sur l'avenir de l'intersyndicale il faut
éviter de risques tuer l'intersyndicale
en repartant comme avant ou faire une
intercelicale permanente qui soit
mentirait à tout le monde car on a des
désaccords soit tétaniserait les
organisations qui s'en tiendraient au
minimum commun c'est vraiment
intéressant
Franck Morel peut-être d'abord sur nous
savons tous ce que c'est que de gérer
des organisations collectives c'est sûr
enfin voilà quand on est leader de la
CFDT ou de la CGT on a une base derrière
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi c'est
une évidence mais il faut quand même le
rappeler quoi ce qui est dit là est
extrêmement important parce que on a
parlé tout à l'heure du mouvement des
gilets jaunes et d'une des
caractéristiques du moment des gilets
jaunes qui étaient justement le refus de
toute forme de représentation et vous
avez souligné à juste titre que un des
points notables de la séquence retraite
et de la manière dont les organisations
syndicales ont géré cette séquence
retraite c'est la capacité justement à
organiser le mouvement de contestation
et maîtriser le mouvement de
contestation et ça c'est extrêmement
précieux mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il y a un certain nombre de de
codes entre guillemets qui régissent
cette capacité à pouvoir organiser le
mouvement de côté station et notamment
le code c'est de trouver le bon
équilibre entre le fait de prendre en
considération ce que la base des
organisations syndicales demandent et ça
a été un point extrêmement important du
côté de la CFDT et qui explique de mon
point de vue en large partie la
difficulté de pouvoir aller sur la
construction de quelque chose mais c'est
important parce que ça a quand même
permis notamment à la CFDT de pouvoir
garder la main sur le mouvement et puis
l'autre versant c'est la capacité à
savoir jusqu'où on peut aller jusqu'où
on peut aller à un moment donné la CFDT
a dit il y a quelques jours ça y est
c'est fini il y a un certain moment dans
le conflit social où ça n'était pas
possible ça n'était pas audible de la
part de ses vendant et avec la capacité
dire ça je ne pourrais pas je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant Christine
est-ce que quand même on peut dire c'est
pas nouveau mais que que dans cette
interdit syndicale Laurent Berger a pris
le lit clairement on l'a bien vu au
centre à chaque fois des des des des
leaders syndicaux rassemblés quand il
fallait prendre la parole non seulement
effectivement sans ça quasiment tous les
jours oui oui tout à fait non mais je
trouve que la photo qu'on a vu plusieurs
fois avec lui entre Martinez et voilà et
les autres les autres patrons des des
syndicats étaient étaient très parlante
parce qu'en fait son syndicat est devenu
le premier en France mais en même temps
il était reconnu par la CGT qu'il était
le premier en France c'était c'était
vraiment ça qui se passait et donc j'ai
trouvé que c'était oui oui c'était voilà
c'est l'image qui restera pour moi aussi
de cette intersey syndicale alors
toujours sur l'unité syndicale
l'intersyndicale écouter Jean-Philippe
tan qu'elle secrétaire général de la
CFE-CGC
comme l'Inter syndical l'a fait sur le
dossier des retraites en se concentrant
sur ce qui la rassemble elle va
travailler dès maintenant à dégager des
revendications communes sur chacun des
sujets suivants les salaires et les
pensions les conditions de travail la
santé au travail la démocratie sociale
l'égalité femme homme l'environnement et
la conditionnalité des aides publiques
aux entreprises sur ces thèmes nous
voulons obtenir des avancées importantes
notamment lors des futurs négociations
alors quand on parle des syndicats et
moi je trouve toujours ça passionnant il
y a le discours national et puis aussi
ce qui se passe sur le terrain et ce
qu'on voit sur le terrain à Rémi
bourguignon c'est qu'il y a l'unité
syndicale elle est aussi à l'oeuvre
parfois dans certaines entreprises c'est
à dire qu'il y a vraiment ce poids d'une
inter syndicale qui est qui fonctionne
comme tel pour obtenir des avancées au
niveau des entreprises est-ce que c'est
vraiment une nouvelle donne de longue
durée pour pour vous c'est-à-dire qu'on
dit une page s'est tournée est-ce que là
aussi c'est une nouvelle donne donc vous
avez raison de faire la distinction
entre ce ça se passe localement et ce
qui se passe au niveau national et au
niveau local effectivement il y a des
entreprises dans lesquelles il y a des
inter syndicales notamment dans les les
conflits un peu durs sur les
restructurations etc mais on a aussi des
entreprises dans lesquelles il y a des
conflits inter syndicaux extrêmement
importants et ça donne souvent la
tendance de la manière dont se déroule
les négociations dans ces entreprises au
niveau national c'est effectivement une
nouvelle donne parce que cette un
syndicale on l'avait pas vu depuis
extrêmement longtemps elle était
compliquée d'ailleurs pour la CFDT la
CGT à construire au début du mandat de
Laurent Berger puisqu'on regarde un peu
cette période là parce qu'il faut se
rappeler que c'est aussi le moment où
arrive Thierry lepont à la CGT et que la
CGT entre dans une crise quand même
assez lourde et pendant un moment donc
les conditions étaient absolument pas
réunies en poste quelques mois à peine
un petit peu plus mais presque deux ans
mais
dans ma tête ça va être durer moins
longtemps que ça mais voilà il va être
mis en difficulté il va y avoir
l'arrivée de Philippe Martinez qui va
être aussi assez compliqué pour assécher
donc il a fallu quelques années pour
avoir des conditions réunies et c'est
important de souligner effectivement que
dans certains syndical on a beaucoup vu
Laurent Berger mais il faut quand même
souligner effectivement l'acceptation du
leadership CFDT par la CGT qui est quand
même un élément extrêmement important
c'est aussi une forme de reconnaissance
de tous nos critères de représentativité
syndicale avec l'élection etc et puis
alors pour les militants CFDT c'est
aussi purposant parce que ils étaient
moins traité de traîtres par par
d'autres d'autres non mais c'est vrai
c'est aussi ça ce qui s'est passé dans
les dans les cortèges je voudrais
revenir vers vous Franck moral sur côté
pour côté gouvernement quoi qu'est-ce
que ça change d'avoir une intersey
syndicale parce qu'on a bien vu là que
la porte elle avait été à peine en
trouves verte par Elisabeth borne avec
des débiles latérales elle a reçu mais
bon on voit pas de grande négociations
point valoris est-ce qu'ils ont peur du
poids de cette interditale quelque chose
par rapport à la maîtrise du mouvement
que par rapport à la dynamique du
processus de réforme bien les choses
telles qu'elles sont parce que dans la
dynamique du processus de réforme j'ai
envie de dire c'est plutôt l'inverse
c'est plutôt peu la capacité à pouvoir
s'appuyer sur un acteur qui ne serait
pas d'accord avec les autres pour
essayer d'avancer avec cet acteur là
c'est pas le cas puisque vous avez une
inter syndicale et vous avez une
position commune de refus de la réforme
de la part de l'insertion syndical oui
mais ça c'était sur les retraites est-ce
que est-ce que ça peut changer est-ce
que ça peut changer sur la suite c'est
moi je me projette là on peut changer
sur la suite sur la suite moi je suis
assez en phase avec ce que disait
Laurent Berger avec le côté assez
pragmatique de la construction inter
syndicale qui est une construction je
dirais pour les besoins de la
circonstance c'est-à-dire qui reste des
syndicats différents avec une histoire
différente avec une culture différente
et dans les prochaines négociations
interprofessionnelles il y en a qui
signeront et d'autres qui signeront pas
et c'était le cas d'ailleurs de en
matière de partage de la valeur c'est le
cas sur les deux autres accords qui ont
été trouvés sur les activités du travail
et sur la transition écologique donc il
faut pas sur interpréter le poids de
l'Inter syndicale je crois que la valeur
ajoutée surtout moi la vraie valeur
ajoutée que je vois très importante
non négligeablement c'est celle de la
maîtrise du mouvement et je renvoie à ce
que j’évoquais tout à l'heure sur les
gilets jaunes elle est elle est notable
alors on va s'intéresser au destin au
futur de Laurent Berger on va forcément
parler de politique il l'a dit tout de
suite à chaque fois que la question lui
opposée il ne veut pas je ne veux pas me
lancer dans la politique mais quand même
Laetitia il aurait pu incarner il
incarner un espoir à gauche alors oui et
même triple oui il le sait tout le monde
le sait et lui en premier le patron de
la CFDT il a toujours mis c'est vrai une
frontière étanche entre le combat
politique et le combat syndical ça on
peut pas lui reprocher mais il s'est
trouvé dans les faits il s'est trouvé
effectivement dans une position inédite
pour lui il s'est retrouvé dans la
position du premier opposant non pas
syndical Thomas du premier opposant
politique à Emmanuel Macron dans les
faits c'est lui qui a incarné le
mouvement de contestation à la réforme
des retraites et il a accepté de jouer
ce rôle j'en parlais tout à l'heure il a
accepté toutes les la méditation médias
faudrait compter vraiment j'ai essayé de
le faire je vous assure il y en avait
trop télé radio web presse écrite il a
dit oui à tout je pense que c'est un
recordman et son message n'a jamais
changé son message c'est le même que
celui qui l'adressait en une par exemple
tiens de libération c'était le 19 mars
dernier regardez cette une ce n'est pas
un échec c'est un naufrage alors je
pourrais vraiment décrypter pendant
trois quarts d'heure la photo mais on le
fera genre on n'a pas le temps je sais
bien quand on avait une émission médium
et là là on va rester sur le fond mais
quand même c'est une il avait mis en
avant sur Twitter Laurent Berger Twitter
et s'en est beaucoup servi aussi un des
médiateurs mais alors Twitter il y a
beaucoup tweeté et il avait écrit sur
Twitter monsieur le Président de la
République par souci d'apaisement et
pour sortir de cette crise sociale et
démocratique ne promulguez pas cette
réforme des retraites donc il avait tout
pour se lancer en politique en quelque
sorte tout le positionnement le
storytelling la curiosité des médias
pour ne pas dire le bon accueil quand
même médiatique et finalement la
question qu'il faudrait poser et que moi
j'aurais vraiment envie de poser à
Laurent Berger c'est mais comment a-t-il
fait pour ne pas y aller comment a-t-il
pu se dérober en décevant toute une
partie du peuple de gauche parce que ils
sont nombreux vous savez parmi 1800
parmi les électeurs parmi les hommes et
les femmes de gauche à avoir cru en lui
avoir cru en le rang berger avoir vu en
sauveur en sauveur un peu providentiel
et peut-être en celui qui ramènerait la
gauche au pouvoir ancien pilier du PS
oui c'est Michel Sapin on se fait un
ministre du Travail sous François
Hollande c'est dans les échos d'ailleurs
il avait dit j'ai retenu j'ai retenu
cette phrase il a dit la réalité et
qu'il est en situation il est en
situation d'aller en politique d'accord
c'est Michel Sapin habitué la petite qui
le dit c'est le meneur celui qui dit des
choses équilibrées et compréhensible
dans un débat incompréhensible pour
l'associal démocratie orpheline il est
le seul qu'il a représente finalement
Laurent Berger a comblé un vide malgré
lui un vide politique et il a suscité
c'est vrai des forts espoirs et
finalement il a renoncé pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a eu je ne sais pas un des
signaux négatifs de la part de la nupes
par exemple parce que il aurait été à
gauche de toute façon Laurent Berger
est-ce qu'il n'a pas eu le courage d'y
aller est-ce que ces convictions
personnelles étaient si forte qu'ils
l'ont empêché de passer finalement ce
pont vers la politique je peux vous
assurer Thomas que ces questions elles
vont lui être posées dans tous les
médias parce que on va le revoir Laurent
Berger il faut peut-être sa semaine
comme ça avec son sac à dos mais on va
le revoir dans les médias il a dit qu'il
voulait continuer à participer au débat
public et donc au débat politique sans
être politique donc il faudra lui
demander vraiment pourquoi il a renoncé
et ne pas s'il n'a jamais il n'a la
réponse à cette question c'est aussi un
message c'est aussi un message c'est
peut-être aussi juste une obsession
journalistique
on peut on peut on pourrait aussi se
dire ça tout le monde ne rêve pas de
devenir candidat candidat à la
présidentielle non mais c'est vraiment
appeler c'est vraiment intéressant
Christine kereland Nicole nota aussi on
attendait à ce qu'elle fasse de la
politique après et elle en a pas fait
c'était une femme on manquait de femmes
non je pense que je pense que
ce qui est assez amusant c'est que vous
avez employé le verbe renoncer pour
renoncer à quelque chose il faut l'avoir
envisagé
et donc la question voilà personne n'est
dans la tête de converger et je ne sais
pas s'il a renoncé ou s'il n'a jamais
envisagé en réalité après il y a deux
facteurs il y a un vous l'avez dit le
fait la faiblesse de la gauche
social-démocrate et donc du coup le fait
de combler un manque d'une certaine
manière ça c'est le premier point et
puis le deuxième facteur que vous avez
pas pointé mais qui me paraît être
important pour alimenter je dirais cette
les
président d'une fondation d'une d'une
grande banque mutualiste ou alors
intégrer une grande entreprise de
l'économie sociale et solidaire en face
ça pourrait ça pourrait être ça je me
mouille je prends je prends mon risque
dans le destin de Laurent Berger mais il
dit effectivement dans le bon article de
des échos ou la plume d'Elsa freysney et
il est là de comarmon qui va s'installe
à une cure de silence c'est une sorte de
tradition à la CFDT de pas gêner les
en l'occurrence celles qui vient après
effectivement je crois qu'il a envie de
ne pas gêner Marie-Lise Léon puisque
c'est lui qui l'a poussé là et il a pas
envie qu'elle qu'elle commence mal mais
pour revenir sur cette non envie d'aller
en politique il n'a jamais dit qu'il est
en politique il a plutôt quand on lui
posait la question dit qu'il voulait pas
y aller je pense qu'il aurait peur de
perdre sa liberté de parole ou ça son
honnêteté non je parlais non je parlais
à l'origine et puis lisons Laurent
Berger toujours dans cet article je ne
veux pas candidater dans
l'administration et les entreprises de
la sphère
[Musique]
privé mais l'extrait que vous avez lu et
est important parce que il faut rappeler
que le prédécesseur de Laurent Berger
avait été nommé à l'Inspection générale
des affaires sociales
et d'autres exemples d'anciens
syndicalistes qui ont intégré des corps
d'inspection et qui se sont reconvertis
voire même parfois en cabinet
ministériel donc c'est assez notable
effectivement alors après ça vient
alimenter sans doute la longue séquence
des du regard porté sur les relations
entre Laurent Berger et le président de
la République bien sûr qui veut pas les
frapper à la porte des des gouvernement
du président pour les leur demander de
le recaser quelque part dans la sphère
publique et d'ailleurs ça m'offre la
transition pour notre conclusion on va
parler de Marylise Léon donc il lui
succède demain je propose d'écouter un
extrait de du interview de Maryse Lyon
c'était il y a il y a deux semaines sur
RTL elle se projetait sur les nez vers
les négociations futures
le sujet important c'est la question de
la méthode c'est à dire que si on renoue
le dialogue c'est certainement pas pour
faire comme on a eu des discussions sur
les retraites donc on est extrêmement
clair et nous attendons du gouvernement
qui nous fasse qui nous explique en quoi
ils sont prêts à travailler différemment
et sur quoi donc pour le moment on est
on est en acte bon il y a pas de dans le
placard l'expression est un peu lourde
mais bon enfin tout le monde comprend ce
que je veux dire entre entre Maryse Léon
et Emmanuel Macron ça va quand même
peut-être simplifier les choses en fait
il ne pars pas cette date n'est pas n'a
pas été prise au hasard c'est bien après
la réforme des retraites comme il avait
promis qu'il ne retournerait jamais à la
table des négociations si ce projet de
retraite était pas retiré et bien le
projet est allé jusqu'au bout donc il
retournera pas à table de négociation
donc il n'a pas assez on peut y aller à
sa place effectivement mais il faut même
noter un point important c'est que vous
allez avoir trois des têtes des trois
principales organisations la CFDP la CGT
est bientôt le Medef qui vont être
nouvelle
et donc effectivement on passe à autre
chose alors est-ce que le passage à
autre chose va se traduire par un
renouveau ou une redynamisation du
dialogue social il y a quelques indices
intéressants avec les accords vous
citiez l'accord partagé la valeur les
deux autres accords qui ont été signés
il y a un rendez-vous négociation sur
les seniors sur lequel il y a beaucoup
d'attentes en direction des partenaires
sociaux on le verra mais en tout cas ce
renouvellement des têtes est propice à
cette redynamisation Marylise Léon elle
va s'inscrire dans le puisqu'on parlait
de du réel pouvoir des des patrons de
syndicats et de leurs liens à leur base
elle va s'inscrire dans la continuité de
l'action en tout cas pour les deux
syndicats CGT CFDT il y a pas avec le
changement de de dirigeant de changement
de ligne majeur il y a pas de virage
très fort le Medef on verra un petit peu
plus tard mais il y a des changements de
personnes et les différents extraits que
vous avez montré
indique bien que c'est quand même une
relation interpersonnelles vous avez
parlé de la relation entre Laurent
Berger et Philippe Martinez qui a été
extrêmement importante pour construire
ce l'Inter syndical ce qu'ils sont
capables de se dire se dire ce qu'ils
peuvent faire pas faire donc ça c'est
beaucoup des questions
d'interpersonnelles donc à partir où
changer les trois têtes dans la même
période et bien l'avenir tout va changer
donc c'est on parlait de l'intersyndical
est-ce que va s'inscrire dans la durée
c'est quand même une bonne partie une
question de relation interpersonnelle et
de des relations vont être capables de
nouer ces personnes oui mais alors
c'était la même chose pour Laurent
Berger et Philippe Martinez ils avaient
des comptes à rendre à leur base là on a
deux nouvelles Marylise Léon et Sophie
Binet à la tête de la célérité qui elles
aussi finalement doivent rendre des
comptes à la alors base donc c'est c'est
une double pression vous voyez ce que je
veux dire la pression de l'opinion la
pression de est-ce qu'on réussit à
obtenir fort de le de d'une inter
syndicale qui a 6 mois de d'existence
derrière de des avancées sociales et
puis à la pression de la base elles vont
devoir vivre avec ça quoi bien sûr ça
c'est la donne fondamentale d'une
organisations syndicale ou patronales il
faut faire avec avec sa base est composé
avec en deux ce point de vue là c'est
presque plus simple pour Marylise Léon
parce qu'on la CFDT est un syndicat très
intégré très homogène alors ce féminin
les conditions de son élection étaient
un peu un peu plus compliqué voilà il y
a les conditions et puis la CGT est un
syndicat quand même très fragmenté avec
des divergences très très fortes donc ça
va être un petit peu plus dur pour se
féminer qui elle va devoir un peu
naviguer entre les différents courants
au sein de la CGT et puis vous l'avez
dit Sophie Binel est condition de son
élection font que ce féminin n'a pas été
élu véritablement sur une ligne on est
bien en peine qui avait été le cas de
Philippe Martinez voilà ce qui avait été
le cas de Philippe Martinez absolument
on est bien en peine de dégager une
ligne derrière l'élection de Sophie
Binet elle a surtout été élu par rejet
des deux autres des deux autres
candidates qui chacune incarnaient
effectivement une forme de ligne ça sera
pas du tout le cas de Marylise néon qui
est une femme très talentueuse moi que
je connais bien que j'ai côtoyé quand
j'étais à Matignon et qui est quelqu'un
qui est très ouvert à la discussion tout
en restant attaché conviction qu'elle
entend qu'elle entend défendre mais elle
a l'avantage effectivement de rester sur
une ligne qui reste la ligne de la CFDT
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vais rappeler Christine
kerdelan le titre de ce livre mon
super-héros livre était publié aux
éditions humaines sciences à bientôt sur
Public Sénat merci encore je vous dis à
demain pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public vous pouvez nous retrouver sur la
plateforme public sénat.fr et puis notez
que l'invité de la matinale demain ce
sera marine tant de lier secrétaire
national d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
belle soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]